europa bekommt einen vierten corona
impfstoff in deutschland gibt es streit
darüber wann auch hausärzte
flächendeckend impfen dürfen
zehn jahre nach fukushima japan gedenkt
der opfer
die folgen der atomkatastrophe sind
längst nicht unter kontrolle und zeit
für neues bundestrainer jogi löw spricht
erstmals über seinen rückzug nach der
europameisterschaft
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport angelo natur von mir wenn
die impfkampagne nicht komplett aus dem
ruder läuft dann werde deutschland im
herbst die kontrolle über das corona
virus erlangen
davon ist der präsident des robert
koch-instituts wieder überzeugt
allerdings gebe es klare zeichen dass
die dritte welle hierzulande bereits
begonnen hat die zahlen steigen wieder
deutlich
binnen eines tages wurden dem rk ii 14
1356 neuinfektionen gemeldet das sind
2444 mehr als vergangenen donnerstag 321
menschen starben in verbindung mit dem
virus der bundesweite sieben tage
incidents wert steigt auf 69,1 immer
drängender wird die frage wann auch
hausärzte impfen dürfen
volker check ralf achim schöffel ist ein
hausarzt alten schlages einer der sich
mit leidenschaft auch im alten modell
projekten beteiligt der 76 jährige hat
für seine praxis im sächsischen bad
elster 600 dosen astra zenica bekommen
das reicht für vier tage
viele seiner betagten patienten scheuen
den gang ins im zentrum
aber jetzt wo mehr dosen kommen sollte
man doch schon loslassen von diesen
impfzentren und sollte das auf die
breiten schultern der hausärzte
verteilen hausarzt oder impfzentrum die
diskussion wirkt fast schon wie eine
glaubensfrage die landesregierung in
dresden hält die impfzentren noch für
effektiver die impfzentren haben den
größten durchsatz dort geht es am
schnellsten mannschaft an einem tag 4
viel mehr personen als wenn man das über
arztpraxen macht deswegen war das der
erste weg und sobald genügend impfstoff
vorhanden ist sollen die arztpraxen auch
dazu kommt bei der logistik schien die
impfzentren lange vorn zu liegen denn
der impfstoff von beyond eck musste
anfangs bei sehr hohen temperaturen
gelagert werden jetzt hat der hersteller
seine angaben aber korrigieren
fünf zentren waren am anfang notwendig
wegen dieser erfordernis der tiefkühlung
und das hat sich eigentlich erübrigt so
dass mir die aus ärzte hausärzte das
übernehmen können nach ansicht von
logistikern schöpfen bund und länder
nicht alle kapazitäten aus neue importe
müssen her
die apotheken auch weitere betriebsärzte
unternehmen bis zur möglichkeit in
rathäusern und an wird um stellen zu
dürfen praxisbesuch mit kamera
begleitung bundesgesundheitsminister
sparen will bei den hausärzten gut
wetter machen
viele verstehen nicht warum sie noch bis
mitte april warten sollen um selbst mit
dem impfen zu beginnen
heute wurden dem robert koch institut
erstmals über 250.000 corona impfungen
innerhalb eines tages gemeldet stunde
mehr impfstoff zur verfügung könnte es
schneller gehen
dabei wird mit vier zahlen jongliert mit
millionen von impfdosen heiko bisa fasst
zusammen wie viele moment überhaupt da
ist und was in den nächsten wochen
erwartet wird
angekündigt war das im ersten quartal
insgesamt etwa 17,7 millionen dosen
impfstoff von biontech pfizer
astrazeneca und moderner geliefert
werden so wie es heute aussieht werden
diese werte erreicht zwölf einhalb
millionen sind schon da
davon sind acht einheit millionen
verimpft das im tempo nimmt konstant zu
im zweiten quartal sollen es dann mehr
als dreieinhalb mal so viele dosen
werden optionen gibt es zudem auf die
impfstoffe von johnson & johnson und
koubek dann soll das impfen richtig
fahrt aufnehmen wenn alle hersteller
liefern können sind fünf millionen
impfungen pro woche rechnerisch möglich
fünfmal so viele wie im moment
die impfzentren schaffen nach ansicht
des gesundheitsministeriums wohl nur
drei millionen
spätestens dann müssten auch arztpraxen
impfen
mit dem impfstoff des us-herstellers
johnson & johnson wird also frühestens
ab april gerechnet
seit heute ist er in der eu zugelassen
nach der prüfung durch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde
er hat zwei vorteile erstens es reicht
eine spritze und zweitens er braucht nur
kühlschrank temperaturen
das macht die verteilung lagerung und
damit auch das impfen einfacher mehr hat
patricia schäfer das bei johnson &
johnson eine impfung ausreicht zeigen
weltweit mehrere studien doktor
christoph spinner leitet eine dieser
studien
ein weiterer vorteil der neue impfstoff
wurde bereits in südafrika und brasilien
getestet wo gefährliche varianten
grassieren und deshalb wissen wir aus
diesen studien dass er auch dort wirksam
ist und zwar vor allem vor schweren ko
witt und co witting der
krankenhausaufnahme oder tod
die wirksamkeit gegen schwere und
schwerste verläufe 85 prozent entwickelt
wurde das neue aktien von johnson &
johnson tochterunternehmen jantzen
es handelt sich um einen sogenannten
vector impfstoff dabei werden adenoviren
die erkältungen auslösen können
bestandteile des corona virus
eingepflanzt der körper entwickelt auf
die erkältungsviren eine abwehrreaktion
und gleichzeitig wird das immunsystem
auch gegen das corona virus trainiert
die immunantwort des körpers baut sich
bis zum fünfzigsten tag nach der impfung
auf und ist am ende stark genug dass
eine dosis ausreicht berichte über
angebliche lieferprobleme wollte das
unternehmen heute nicht bestätigen und
verspricht pünktliche zustellung im
moment planen wir in der zweiten
aprilhälfte mit der lieferung zu
beginnen und werden bis ende des jahres
200 millionen impfdosen an die eu
liefern
das ist komplett organisiert organized
zehn millionen dieser impfdosen gehen im
zweiten quartal nach deutschland das
unternehmen plant außerdem in zukunft
auch in deutschland zu produzieren
ein impfstoffhersteller macht heute auch
negative schlagzeilen astrazeneca wenn
dänemark und norwegen ist die impfung
mit dem wirkstoff des herstellers
vorläufig ausgesetzt
die gesundheitsbehörde in kopenhagen
prüft berichte über schwere
blutgerinnsel untersucht wird ob sie mit
einer corona impfung in verbindung
stehen könnten
daraufhin stoppte auch oslo vor sich
vorsorglich die impfungen mit
astrazeneca der us kongress hat das 1,9
billionen dollar schwere krone
hilfspaket von präsident biden
verabschiedet eines der umfangreichsten
konjunkturprogramme aller zeiten
der größte teil sind soforthilfen 1400
dollar sollen bedürftige bürger erhalten
weitere milliarden sind für die
wirtschaft sowie schulen und
universitäten vorgesehen
biden will durch das hilfspaket außerdem
die impfkampagne vorantreiben
die cdu/csu-fraktion im bundestag kommt
nicht zur ruhe
marc hauptmann aus thüringen liegt als
dritter unionsabgeordnete in dieser
woche sein mandat nieder
anlass sind korruptionsvorwürfe gegen
den 36 jährigen
er pflegte enge kontakte nach
aserbaidschan bestreitet aber geld
angenommen zu haben
zuvor hatten die abgeordneten nüßlein
und löbel die fraktion verlassen müssen
wegen umstrittener geschäfte mit corona
schutzmasken mathis feldhoff sein
auftreten immer jung smart und gut
vernetzt heute ist mag hauptmann cdu
abgeordneter aus thüringen über sein
engagement für aserbaidschan gestolpert
das land das noch vor vier monaten einen
blutigen krieg im südkaukasus führte ist
wahrlich kein beispiel für demokratie
und menschenrechte
ob es der connections gibt das kann ich
nicht bewerten mag kaufmann hat uns
gegenüber versichert es gebe keine und
er habe nie geld bekommen wenn einer von
hauptmann herausgegebenen cdu zeitung
kann man einen anderen eindruck bekommen
immer wieder lobes artikel in
südthüringen kurier über baku gepard
auch mal mit einer anzeige für
granatapfelsaft aus dem südkaukasus zu
viel näher liegt ein
hauptmann ist damit in einer reihe mit
axel fischer und karin strenz auch
cdu-abgeordnete alle drei eint ihr lob
für aserbaidschan gegen fischer und
strenz wird ermittelt wegen
bestechlichkeit
hintergrund ist eine pro aserbaidschan
erklärung im europarat 2016 fischer und
strenz so der verdacht hätten auf
weisung aus baku dafür gestimmt also bei
chan ist ja nicht frankreich sondern
eine brutale diktaturen wer von
diktaturen geld annimmt
ob direkt oder durch schmutzige
geschäfte der hat in der politik nichts
verloren diese eiterbeulen werden jetzt
auf gestochen das ist für den moment
hässlich aber ist tut für die
grundreinigung gut
am abend wird bekannt dass hauptmann
offenbar auch mit fragwürdigen masken
geschäften in verbindung steht die idee
berichtet von geldzahlungen an
strohfirmen geleistet von landratsämtern
in thüringen als abidjan scheint nicht
der einzige grund für den rücktritt zu
sein
zehn jahre ist er jetzt her der
verheerenden atomunfall im japanischen
fukushima damals löst ein starkes
erdbeben einen tsunami aus mehr als
18.000 menschen sterben und das
atomkraftwerk in fukushima wird
überflutet
in drei reaktoren kommt es zur
kernschmelze radioaktive stoffe treten
aus ein problem ist seitdem ungelöst die
zerstörten reaktoren müssen mit wasser
gekühlt werden
das kann aber nur teilweise gefiltert
werden und so türmen sich auf dem
gelände immer mehr tanks mit teilweise
radioaktiv verseuchtem wasser
diese tanks sind gewaltig wie sie sehen
inzwischen stehen mehr als 1000 davon
auf dem gelände alle randvoll und
täglich kommen bis zu 180 tonnen
kontaminiertes wasser dazu heißt jede
woche ein weiterer tank wohin damit
steht an die schöne baum
die wasserbehälter stehen wie ein
mahnmal in fukushima daiichi und der
platz wird eng
mehr als 1,2 millionen tonnen
radioaktiven wassers müssen entsorgt
werden
die japanische regierung hat entschieden
dass es nach und nach ins meer geleitet
werden soll
das sehen viele kritisch nur klären müll
in den weltmeeren zu entsorgen wurde vor
vielen jahren schon durch internationale
verträge verboten
japan möchte mit hilfe einer pipeline
dieses verbot umgehen das ist nicht
akzeptabel
mehr als 500.000 menschen mussten
fliehen vor dem erdbeben dem tsunami der
nuklearen katastrophe als es zur
explosion in reaktor blöcke kommt dem
super gau der das land und die menschen
verseuchte bis heute logo areas 30
kilometer rund um das atomkraftwerk ist
die zeit stehengeblieben stumme zeugen
der katastrophe zum ersten mal seit 2011
kehrt taca china klima mit einer
freundin zurück an den ort in dem so
viele freunde von ihnen einst lebten
sehen sie sich das an all diese häuser
aber niemand kann hier leben eine stadt
ohne menschenleben
so sieht es nach zehn jahren aus das ist
schrecklich
[Musik]
heute vor zehn jahren um 14 uhr 46 bebte
die erde in japan
im gedenken an die opfer eine
schweigeminute im ganzen land
und die katastrophe war viele fragen auf
auch in deutschland mit konsequenzen
die bundesregierung steuerte einen ganz
neuen kurs raus aus der atomenergie
ein ehrgeiziger und teurer ausstiegsplan
wurde in gang gesetzt bis ende 2022
sollen die letzten deutschen
kernkraftwerke vom netz gehen elisabeth
schmidt berichtet über die folgen eines
tages der vor zehn jahren die welt
erschütterte mit einer stärke von 8,9
erschüttert ein verheerendes erdbeben
japan die naturkatastrophe und der gau
in japan führen zu einem beben in der
deutschen politik atomausstieg sofort
wenige monate zuvor hatte die schwarz
gelbe koalition die reaktorlaufzeiten
noch verlängert von den damals 17 akw
sind heute noch 6 in betrieb
2022 soll das letzte vom netz gehen
das war absolut richtig und ist richtig
aus der atomenergie auszusteigen und wir
wollen dass möglichst viele staaten sich
uns anschließen und zu sicheren
energieformen nämlich zur energie aus
wind oder sonne übergehen
auch das krisenmanagement von bund und
ländern wird weiter überarbeitet
erst seit fukushima sind schwerste
unfälle teil der notfallplanung in
deutschland fukushima hat uns gezeigt
vor zehn jahren dass ein unfall auch in
hoch technologisierten land wie japan
wie auch deutschland nicht
ausgeschlossen ist und deswegen müssen
wir uns gut darauf vorbereiten größere
evakuierungsflüge millionen jodtabletten
deutschland will für den ernstfall
gerüstet sein auch weil viele
nachbarländer beim erreichen der
klimaziele noch lange zeit auf atomstrom
setzen
aus kostengründen selbst wenn die
reaktoren in die jahre kommen
es gebe bessere reaktoren tüten und es
gibt sichere kraftwerke und gesetzen
nach wie vor in europa auf die alte
garde der atomausstieg hat seinen preis
allein für die zwischen- und endlagerung
des radioaktiven mülls sind in
deutschland rund 170 milliarden euro
eingeplant
der chinesische volkskongress hat eine
änderung des wahlrechts in der
sonderverwaltungszone hongkong
beschlossen beging erhält damit
kontrolle über die kandidaten
außerdem soll ein komitee die
regierungsspitze sowie eine große anzahl
der abgeordneten bestimmen damit
verschärft china die kontrolle über
hongkong weiter nach dem umstrittenen
sogenannten sicherheitsgesetz im
vergangenen jahr ungarn und polen klagen
gegen den rechtsstaat mechanismus der eu
damit wollen die beiden länder mögliche
sanktionen verhindern
der mechanismus sieht vor dass zahlungen
der eu an mitgliedsstaaten gekürzt
werden dürfen etwa wenn sie die
unabhängigkeit der justiz einschränken
eine entscheidung des europäischen
gerichtshofes wird erst im nächsten jahr
erwartet home office mehr
videokonferenzen mehr austausch von
daten die korona krise hat der
digitalisierung in deutschen unternehmen
einen schub gegeben der auch dringend
nötig ist schaut man sich den
europäischen vergleich an auf platz 18
rangiert deutschland da tendenz
allerdings fallen
zum einen sind andere länder schneller
zum anderen ist die entwicklung in den
einzelnen unternehmen durchaus
unterschiedlich das zeigt jetzt eine
studie der kfw
besonders an tina bei der einfahrt in
dieses auto haus in oberursel wird das
kennzeichen gefilmt und gespeichert beim
reinfahren in die werkstatt der
reifendruck automatisch überprüft und
ein fahrzeug scanner registriert dann
mögliche karosserie schäden alles wird
digital an eine zentrale datenbank
weitergeleitet auf die dann auch die
monteure zugriff haben
schon vor fünf jahren hat das autohaus
die digitalisierung gestartet und
profitiert sehr in der korona zeit für
unsere kunden waren kontaktlose
fahrzeugabgabe möglich wir haben viele
unserer mitarbeiter im home office
arbeiten lassen können durch die
digitalisierung und in unseren
werkstätten natürlich effektivität
generiert als teil einer großen
unternehmensgruppe ist in diesem
autohaus auch das nötige geld da bei
kleineren unternehmen sieht es oft
anders aus die kfw stellt fest
ein drittel der betriebe vor allem
kleinere haben überhaupt nicht
digitalisiert und die unternehmen die
ihre digitalisierungs aktivitäten
verstärkt oder ausgebaut haben
sind solche unternehmen die besonders
stark von der krise betroffen sind und
von der langen krise n'dour ausgehen das
ist nicht eine langfristige
digitalisierungsstrategie kleineren
unternehmen fehlt oft das geld und
fachpersonal für eine digitalisierung
außerdem haben die meisten fördergelder
einen großen haken da muss man natürlich
schon in vorkasse treten also betriebe
unserer größenordnung damals zehn 20.000
euro lockerzumachen auch so ist
natürlich schon schwieriger so dürften
autohäuser wie das in oberursel die
ausnahme bleiben und deutschland im
eu-vergleich immer mehr den anschluss
verlieren
und jetzt kannst du uns mehr zu jogi löw
sagen er hat heute erstmals öffentlich
stellung bezogen zu seinem rückzug nach
der eben ein ganz entspannt wirkende
noch bundestrainer der mit sich und
seiner entscheidung im reinen ist ein
nachfolger der soll erst im september
benannt werden volle konzentration jetzt
erstmal auf die kommende em den ausstieg
bereits vor der europameisterschaft
bekannt zu geben begründet joachim löw
so ich wollte es auch vor den
länderspielen machen damit wir uns da
wir dort konzentrieren können auf die
länderspiele und auch dass der verein in
ruhe eben auch die zeit nutzt und sich
gedanken macht was ich denn die richtige
lösung für danach jetzt aber komme
allein die zeit der sportlichen
konzentration auf die em
auch wenn bereits viel über die
nachfolge spekuliert werde ich werde in
den nächsten zeit auch keine kandidaten
kommentieren oder zwischenstands
meldungen geben das wäre verkehrt der
firma genug experten in deutschland egal
wie die em ausgehen wird joachim löw
wird als weltmeister trainer in
erinnerung bleiben leipzig ist im
achtelfinale der champions league gegen
liverpool ausgeschieden
rb in weiß mit wenigen chancen gegen die
vor allem in der zweiten halbzeit starke
elf von trainer jürgen klopp mo salou
schoss die reds in der 70 minute in
führung und vier minuten später machte
man den viertelfinaleinzug klar
leipzig hatte bereits das hinspiel
mit 0 2 verloren das ioc will für die
athletinnen und athleten der
sommerspiele in tokio unter winterspiele
in peking impfstoff in china kaufen
der deutsche olympische sportbund hat
dies generell begrüßt will aber für die
eigenen sportler nur impfstoffe
einsetzen die in deutschland zugelassen
sind
zum biathlon weltcup im tschechischen
nove mesto heute der sprint der männer
über zehn kilometer unter siegte der
franzose council für jona je vor dem
norweger tarjei bö und dem italiener
lukas hofer bester deutscher auf platz
morgen der 7,5 sprint der 7,5 kilometer
sprint der frauen ab 17 15 uhr im zdf
aktuell warnt der deutsche wetterdienst
vor orkanböen im schwarzwald wie es
morgen weitergeht dazu gleich mehr von
katja rohwetter slomka freut sich auch
sie im heute journal
und wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen
wieder dabei sind alles gute ihm darauf
wieder sehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das
sturmtief klaus brachte nicht nur
orkanartige sturmböen in wuppertal mit
103 kilometer pro stunde sondern auch
orkanböen zum beispiel auf dem brocken
im harz mit 140 kilometer pro stunde
aber auch an der nordsee nämlich in böse
mit 122 kilometer pro stunde
gut zu erkennen sind hier auch die
kräftigen schauer die da von westen
heran gezogen sind da waren auch einige
gewitter dabei und die beschäftigen uns
auch in der nacht das sind nicht nur
regen sondern zum teil auch
schneeregenschauer und es bleibt zum
teil auch noch recht windig an der
ostsee und auch im schwarzwald da wird
es wohl am längsten stürmen bei
temperaturen in der nacht zwischen 6 und
1 grad und morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 6 grad hier
im westerzgebirge im thüringer wald und
im vogtland und am alpenrand und bis zu
13 grad am oberrhein
morgen vormittag ist der stunde erst mal
durch das wird also ein freundlicher
freitag vormittag denn die meisten
schauer sind aus deutschland abgezogen
nachmittags aber kommt dann das nächste
kleine tief heran
das bringt wieder regen mit und gewitter
und es bringt auch schon wieder wird das
sieht dann in der nacht zu samstag weg
aber am samstag kommt der nächste sturm
luis heißt der mit viel wind danach wird
es deutlich kälter und dann kann es auch
wieder häufiger schneien schönen abend
noch